what's up nicholas hey john how's it
going
good what's going on man hey man i'm
looking for some advice
um stemming from a the peer group i grew
up with
yes growing up you know all my friends
and i we all grew up pretty poor i think
the richest of us now as an adult
looking back was maybe
lower middle class um
i'm still friends with almost all my
friends from middle school
i just kind of went down a different
path in the military
i started learning about finance
economics and politics
and uh dropped out or finished
the degree i was working on went right
back into school for a completely
separate ip degree
and now i'm a little after 30 and
i'm obsessed with finance i'm obsessed
with investing i work in i.t and i make
good money i still got all the same
friends
and not a single one of them has made a
a progressive move in their life in the
last 10 years
and i've been like harping on them and
harping on them and trying
everything i could to like get them with
some sort of vision
goal some sort of progress five year
plan
one year plan anything and i can't get a
single one of them
to care about anything more than how to
maximize their time playing video games
hmm
you love those guys huh yeah frustrating
huh
same four or five guys since middle
school
dude i'm i'm in the exact same boat man
the exact same boat i've got some of my
friends are
as old as i am like our parents knew
each other when they were pregnant
right yeah dude and you love love love
those guys
and you've been able to turn a corner in
your life that they
haven't um
man did you all have some hilarious
stories growing up just straight hijinks
i mean not that i'm gonna talk about on
air
i don't know what statue of limitations
are yes
yes all right here's the here's the good
of it in the heart of it
okay those guys love you they don't give
a crap about your job
they love you you're just there one of
the guys and can i tell you this
and i've learned this how you're just
over 30
yeah i was about 38 or maybe 39 even
um when it finally started leaking out a
little bit
dude your friends are so proud of you
you're the dude that made it
like you got out and when you hear
something like that
you look back at the people that you
love and you're like what are you doing
you can
it's not hard you can just take this
some of them aren't going to because
they choose not to
some of them aren't going to because
their experiences plus their genetics
plus their decisions plus their brain
chemistry plus plus plus
that's just not going to make they're
not going to make it
and they are so proud of you dude and
they love you
and your job is not to make them have a
five year plan
or to make sure that they're not smoking
whatever they're smoking or going to
whatever
your job is just to love them and to
make sure y'all are still laughing and
telling those old jokes
make sure they know you're available if
they need something
and it was a hard conversation with me
with my buddies when i was like hey guys
why don't you guys why don't you guys
and they were like
dude we don't care one of one of my old
gang their dad died
went back we all hung out we all told
stories we all laughed we all
drank some and we laughed some more and
i got to see
their parents who are now old and um
it was a beautiful time and dude they
were just proud of me and they just love
me
they're not going to change their life
and i know that's hard and frustrating
you may need even more in that
but at the end of the day your job is
just to be their friend
and if they ever do call awesome and if
they don't
awesome right could i
could i ask you a follow-up please do
you ask me anything man uh
so currently i'm spending
um you know through various means um
i'm spending hundreds of dollars a month
um trying to help them out don't do that
yeah the biggest thing i'm doing right
now is uh i my
i bought a a large house which was
renovated into a triplex
yeah and i'm renting out two of the
units to two of my friends
um for after utilities a couple hundred
dollars a month
yeah um and i was hoping that they would
take
you know the extra hundreds of dollars a
month that they would be saving to do
something
intelligent with it and you know for the
first couple months it worked and now
that it's been
near a year they're doing stuff like
getting
elaborate tattoos that they can't afford
instead of paying down their car that
they couldn't afford and
they're buying new uh gaining you know
video gaming equipment that they can't
afford instead of
you know you know getting their child
into like the extracurricular activities
that they can't afford
so here you go nicholas you can love
them but you can't save them
you can love them but you can't save
them and and and
and there's a tendency to feel guilty
because you got out
because you made some different life
choices don't feel guilty about who
you've become
of the hard work you've worked through
the hard work you've got to come at some
point you're gonna have to be less
obsessed with
accomplishment and achievement and
finance and job
and and and and at some point you're
gonna have to reckon with nicholas
because here's the worst part dude
however successful you become old
nicholas is gonna follow
you around with you until you deal with
them but that's not for today that's not
for this call
but yeah you can love your friends man
but you can't save them
if you've got the disposable income just
to let them live
you can do that um i don't mix that kind
of stuff
i don't loan my friends money um i don't
give them money they don't call me for
it either
if they want to talk through any
situation in their life if they wanted
to call you for some help with it
i'll be there any anytime and they know
that and they call
right when they're dealing with
challenges with their kids or their
family or whatever
um i don't send them a bill these are my
brothers for years and years and years
and years but i don't send them money
and i don't hire them right
i wouldn't hire them i love them i
wouldn't hire them
and they don't hire me right but you
can't save them and this is going to be
an awkward unwinding of this
right how you're going to get them out
of this
house it's going to be hard huh
well i mean
sometimes they make it feel like it can
be very easy
right because like i i've made it clear
to them
you know when they moved in like i'm
trying to help you out
and then you know when for example one
of them
um blows like i think he blew like four
hundred dollars on his new girlfriend's
kid's christmas presents and then was
late on my rent
i know nicholas went down and i was like
dude you're you're spending my
money i'm giving to you as charity
listen that's the problem that's the
problem
that's the problem they're not they're
spending their money
they're spending their money
they are taking your hook up because
brothers hook up brothers but they're
spending their money and that's the
problem with
cutting deals with giving money loaning
money to
friends and family is it creates a wedge
in the relationship
if they were just being idiots getting
tattoos you would sit by them
while they're playing video games and
you'd be like you're an idiot or when
y'all are
grabbing something to eat you'd be like
that is the stupidest thing
but since you are now in a financial
business relationship with these guys
now you are starting to get into the why
are you spending that's mine that that's
as you just said that's my money here's
the deal nicholas it's not it's their
money
you gave them a good deal on rent so my
recommendation is to
go back to just being friends with these
guys get out of doing business get out
of
interfering in their life get out of
thinking that their decisions are your
decisions their bank accounts or your
bank accounts their money is your money
and this is hard because you love them
let them know how you guys got a few
months and then i got to rent this out
because i got to make some money
oh bro it's bull crap dude yep it is
you can even buy buy drinks you can do
it um you can take them all out to
dinner or something
but at the end of the day love them
you can love them all day long but you
can't save them you can't save them